it's apparent obviously that you can't
travel backwards in time even if you
have a pretty isolated system it would
be difficult to rearrange all the
information contained within it to
return it to a prior state and time much
like trying to fit the pieces of a
broken teacup back together but what you
might not be aware of is that space and
time share a similar feature in this
regard that is just as you can't return
to a prior location in time neither can
you do so in space
[Music]
this is dialect with why you can't
travel backwards in space
the concept here is actually pretty
simple consider that you're traveling
between two locations say the office add
your house at the start of the day you
leave your house and head to the office
at the end of the day you leave the
office and head back to the house now
you've returned to the same location in
space that you are at at the beginning
of the day right well that's not exactly
the case because while you are at work
during the day the earth rotated this
means that going back to the same
location in space would require
traveling all the way back to the point
in space where your house was located
when you first left ok but maybe you
think there's a way around this you can
just wait 24 hours until the earth makes
a complete rotation on its axis thereby
returning your house to its same
location but then you need to consider
that during those 24 hours the earth was
hurtling through space at 19 miles a
second in its orbit around the Sun thus
you are now approximately 1.6 million
miles away when the position in space
where your house was located when you
first left of course it gets even more
complicated because the solar system
itself is traveling at 143 miles a
second through the Milky Way galaxy thus
if you waited about 24 hours to return
to your house you would be at least
approximately twelve point three million
miles from your initial location in
space and that's not even considering
the fact that the Milky Way galaxy is
moving through the Virgo cluster and
that the Virgo cluster is moving through
the land is supercluster and will you
get the picture so what does this all
mean well ultimately we don't know the
extent of the universe or how fast we
are moving through it the consequence of
this restriction on our knowledge is
that it is impossible for us to define a
prior location in space in any absolute
or global sense you can't say I'm going
to return to the location in space where
I was a minute ago if you don't know in
which direction or how fast you are
traveling through space and if you can't
establish a prior location in space then
you can't establish a backwards
direction in space since the notion of
backwards inherently refers to one's
prior location in time hence these
considerations demonstrate that to
travel backwards in space is impossible
of course you might imagine having total
and perfect knowledge of the universe
then perhaps you could calculate how
everything is moving in relation to a
fixed boundary and from there identify
points of global space but this requires
a number of assumptions about the
universe that for reasons not worth
getting into here we aren't justified in
making the only way to truly travel
backwards in space then would be to
rearrange all the objects you are moving
relative to into a position that is in
perfect relation to where they were when
you were first at your prior location
that is you would have to travel
backwards in time like putting the
shattered teacup back together traveling
backwards in space requires you
rearranging all the information in a
system back to an earlier state this is
fascinating because it hints at an
enigmatic relationship between space and
time just as time is perceived to flow
so too is space always flowing carrying
us forward with it whether we like it or
not the fact that an observer can only
travel in a forwards direction also
means that there is as much of an arrow
to space as there is to time we can see
this a little more deeply through an
analogy with entropy and the second law
of thermodynamics if you know a little
about entropy you know that systems
don't spontaneously reoccur two
improbable states a fact that physicists
often hypothesize is responsible for
giving time its forward Direction well
there's a sort of entropy that governs
spatial systems to consider an object
enclosed in a fixed boundary as that
boundary grows larger and larger it
becomes less and less likely that the
object will ever be able to traverse a
location where it was at earlier
thus the chance of seeing a prior
spatial configuration repeat itself
decreases with increasing system size
of course none of this is to say that
you can't define a backwards direction
in space locally using the relative
distances of objects in your immediate
vicinity like say your office and your
house you can establish a fixed boundary
for your system from which back and
forth space travel is readily possible
but it's interesting to think that
ultimately this is really only an
approximation you may think that after
work you had the freedom to return to
the same place you were at at the
beginning of the day but this is only an
illusion as they say you could never
truly go home again
this is dialect thanks for watching